c'est tout nouveau en france et puis
dans l'âme asie dans la quasi majorité
des pays européens alors le procès d air
chaud utilisé contre la mérule au
danemark et en allemagne contre les
insectes xylophages
alors ça c'est un système de chauffage
qui adapté au traitement air chaud alors
le concept il est très simple à
l'intérieur on a un groupe où leur avion
il va aspirer de l'air à l'extérieur
donc via ce ventilateur là qui va t'ont
poussé l'air à travers le chauffage on
va réchauffer le chauffage est ensuite
l'air pénètre dans l'habitat via des
gaines flexible ça va être moins cher
que la méthode traditionnelle tout
simplement parce qu'on ne va pas avoir
beaucoup de travaux de démolition et de
reconstruction derrière